[Musique]
je vois lors notre passé moulié qu'est
ce qu'on voulait à cette heure-là savoir
si vous avez une chambre de libre avec
le sang tout
pour les jambes wade vous même à ça mais
de monter et la maison on n'aime ni les
chèques ni le plastique que le liquide
pour car débarrassées mois merci ça te
reste propre je déteste des arbres vous
trouverez pas sur les portes
jo les portes alors c'est encore yacine
ont offert un beau doublé
est ce que vous pouviez me ranger les
les chaises et les tables qui sont sur
la terrasse pour le bien sûr je savais
plus à plaindre qu autre chose n'en voit
bien que c'est pas vous connaître de
3000 euros
il faut pas que tu mettre le doigt dans
l'engrenage avec 1,6 non seulement
attrape tout mais vous avez réussi à
faire marcher la machine à café
savourez vos petits arbres aussi
[Musique]
j'essaie de vous aider écouter n'essayez
pas ne saurait - mon établissement c'est
sans espoir
vous reprenez vos bagages de retard je
me disais beaucoup a dit qu'il voit que
du jus d'abricot c'est louche
non ne croyez pas méchant ça ne va pas
du tout mais qui tremblaient smith a
braconné fait pas tout plaquer pour
qu'on me fasse tourner en bourrique
comme avant c'est fini les chieuses
signaux un embout savarin quand je le
dis quelques des branques dans ce
village
[Musique]
ta tête de laisser marcher dessus aussi
une bonne à voile et temps en temps ça
je suis pas fier mais je comprenais pas
qu'il faut que je parte
[Musique]
toujours si vous étiez un gangster